We feel like it's time for us to switch
gears with kind of what the con what
content we're going to create.
>> It's a hard decision for us to come to,
but we think it'll be worth it.
>> All right.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> I think that was all higher pitches
successfully.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Well,
>> we got an announcement.
>> We're just jumping right in.
>> We're jumping right in. I mean, just let
the chat out of the bag. I don't like
secrets.
>> Isn't that what we do on the show?
>> Tell us what's the announcement
>> after how many years? We started this in
2018.
>> I don't know if it was 18 or 17. I can't
remember.
>> Okay. So, we the very first LED live
that we ever did, we did the Marvel
>> Satan's Endgame. Satan's
>> Endame. one of the most bestwatched
video. Well, the best watched video till
this point.
>> Actually, the first
>> I don't know if that's a good thing to
admit.
>> It's like we just went downhill from
there.
>> It didn't ever get more than that.
>> But I'll tell you what, we are going and
you know, we took we took a little bit
of time and we sat down with some of the
the people that had their lives changed
by this particular ministry.
>> Mhm.
>> What did they say?
I mean, I've always had good comments
from people.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Might have burned some movies, DVDs, you
know, had a little bonfire outside.
>> Well, there's a lot of people who use
this on a regular basis in their
families and,
>> you know, to help educate themselves,
their children. They use it as
thoughtprovoking conversational pieces
and their
>> youth groups and all kinds of stuff. I
mean, our numbers say, you know, you
have this many views. In reality, it's
probably a lot higher than that. Like
individuals watching
>> because it's watched in groups. I mean,
we've had people tell us, "Yeah, we get
to group with like a 30 group, 30 people
or something."
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Some people use it, you know, in
church for small groups and all those
kind of things, but um we feel like it's
time for us to switch gears with kind of
what the con the what content we're
going to create.
>> Yes. And there's a reason for that.
>> Yeah. I think that one of the big
reasons that uh we started this ministry
was really to use creativity to inspire
people and talk about current events and
and things that were out there. I think
the podcast thing was just really like
an easy shooting fish in a barrel kind
of a deal. And um you know when we
really sit down and we talk with people
who are have had their life changed by
something that they've seen from our
ministry, it seems that they gravitate
towards the more highly produced
versions of the video.
>> That's true.
>> Yep.
>> And so as much as we love this
conversation piece, which I know you
guys are extremely happy to uh
>> That's don't put that in the edit. I
actually know what I was told just just
this past weekend was you don't talk
very much on the show.
>> I kind of want to hear some of the
things you have to say.
>> That's funny.
>> You're taking the microphone away from
the guy that always talks.
>> Yeah.
No,
>> I think though for the best bang for our
buck, we have a unique ministry that has
had a unique voice in being able to put
together um really creative pieces of
information um but also do it in a style
that that is,
>> you know, it's it's it's not something
that everybody can do.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's the reason we went back to this
is because the other one is harder.
>> Yeah.
>> To be honest,
>> it just takes more time to produce.
>> It is actually harder. takes more time
to produce. It takes a lot of thought, a
lot of energy, a lot more of of of sort
of honing in on exactly what you want to
say. But that's what I like about it is
that you can be more purposeful for what
you say. And um so we're going to hit
the pause button, please.
>> Yeah. Doesn't mean we'll never ever ever
do LD Live again. It's just not going to
be in the near future. You're also going
to see less content or not less, but
less frequently. We're not going to prod
maybe put out a video every single week.
It might be every couple of weeks, but
that means we're actually putting in a
lot of effort and time and creativity
into what we're producing.
>> Yep.
>> And the whole goal for us, like this
ministry exists because we want to save
souls. And so we believe if we put more
time and effort into every single video
we put out, which is what you see the
bigger YouTubers doing like Mark Robber
and Mr.
If you put more effort into it, more
creativity,
then you're going to eventually reach
more people with that message. And
that's the reason why we're saying pause
on LD Live. Let's focus on this. So,
more LED style videos, mini documentary
style videos that really get a powerful
message.
>> We're already in production on one.
Yeah, we're actually in production on a
couple of them. Yeah. But um we want you
guys out there to still feel like you
have a very active role in our ministry.
We're always listening to people that
go, "Hey, we'd love this topic or this
topic." In fact, a lot of people send us
content, which really helps us out.
>> Um some of the things we don't have time
to always scour every corner of the
internet. And so we actually get ideas
from you guys. And um you know if
there's um something that you really
liked, we want to make these videos
sharable. That's the idea is if we make
them more better produced, more potent,
more something that you feel like you
can go to work and be like, "Dude, I
just saw this crazy video. You guys have
to see this video." That's literally
what we want to do in producing these
videos.
>> Yeah. And we've hired another person. We
will he will yet be nameless and
anonymous, but at some point we will
share who he is. Probably we'll share
who he is with our
>> donor Patreon uh base. So, and also we
post
>> on our donor Patreon pages and and and
if you donate through the website, you
get these emails as well with updates.
We post on there what we're up to. So,
we post on there pictures of our
productions, videos of our productions.
In fact, someone's walking around right
now who's an intern and she's videoing a
behind the scenes of where we're doing a
day in the life of Little Life Studio.
So, all of these things you can get on
Patreon, including what actual videos
are coming out.
>> Yeah. With that said, people may be
thinking, well, you know, my 24-hour
access to my weekly video, you know,
that's going away, but we're planning on
putting out more content in the behind
thescenes realm and all that. So, we may
>> tweak our awards. We may have to think
about tweaking our rewards for our our
dollar a month patrons, you know, to
make sure that they're getting value.
>> Well, that's actually a good point. We
we want to add value to this.
>> We want to add value.
>> We don't want to take value away. And
so, you know, I want to encourage all of
you guys out there that that do support.
Um, you know, this is actually um a step
up in terms of hardness for us.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, um, we're willing to take the
challenge. Um, you know, we're willing
to skim. Like right now it's really cold
in the office because we don't have the
heat.
>> We're literally freezing up here.
>> It still takes support. Even if it's
taking us a little longer to put out
videos, it still takes support. So, we
appreciate all of you who believe in
this ministry, who believe in what we're
doing,
>> and we still need your help.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We appreciate everybody that's
been supporting all these years. And uh
even though early life has been the
bread and butter, we're willing to take
the risk for the sake of getting more
this message in front of more viewers by
posting less frequently, but posting
absolute like banger projects that
hopefully every single time someone sees
a video of ours on YouTube, they're
like, "Oh my goodness, another one's
come out. I have to watch this because
I've waited for a couple of weeks for
this." And that's the point that people
are can't wait to watch this and hear
the message of the gospel. That's a hard
decision cuz we know there's a lot of
people who have been tuning in weekly.
We've basically not missed a week.
>> Yeah. Never.
>> For many years.
>> Ever. Yeah.
>> Like 360 some odd videos.
>> Maybe been late, but we've never missed.
>> Yeah. So, that's a hard it's a hard
decision for us to come to. Um
>> but we think it'll be worth it.
>> Yeah. And you'll see these maybe um you
know, if we have something that pops up
that that we really would like to have a
discussion. I mean this might this might
be something that we just offer our
Patreon donors or something that you
know the discussion on on on a
particular topic that um you know people
who really support our work want to hear
our thoughts on on why we made that
piece or whatever. So
>> you know this format may not totally go
away but
>> well we'll probably still use it for
Patreon videos as well for like videos
that have nothing to do with our show or
anything. We might just sit here and use
the set for that or or you know like for
example I talked about this before we
started shooting this the Charlie Kirk
assassination that you have to react so
quick. So then this is a good format to
use for that. But otherwise, you know,
if we can do we call it evergreen
projects, evergreen videos, things that
are just kind of like longstanding and
they kind of always are around um you
know, maybe certain celebrities or maybe
uh like Transformers is an evergreen
project, Harry Potter is an evergreen
project, those kind of things. Then you
know, we can just put our time and
effort into it and make it a really
outstanding production. Um, so maybe
instead of us being more like a podcast
YouTube channel, we're turning more into
a production documentary YouTube
channel, which is actually how we
started. We started with well, speaking
engagements and then documentary. So,
we're just going back to our roots.
>> So, this is not goodbye. It's see you
later.
>> See you later. See you later. LED live.
LED live is going to take a rest.
>> Goodbye. for now.